okay I'm dawn Ross I was and I did my
PhD in
but I've been variously held constant
philosophy and economics for the last
money years at the moment I was a endow
philosophy department as recently as
2010 but at the moment I'm exclusively
into economics department is a team in
I've been interested in the unification
of economics with other sciences and by
that I don't just mean analytic
unification in fact they don't mean
analytic unification at all
I mean understanding both large and
small economic systems as the as the
information processing systems that they
are and understanding how such
information processing systems fit into
the larger domain of information
processing systems in the world
the in I also have recently moved
reading a book with the philosopher
physics James ladyman called everything
must go
metaphysics naturalized and the argument
of that book is that philosophers for
the most part analytic philosophers
particularly have to really promote
naturalism in and and and and give it
its proper innings because of lingering
commitments to pre-scientific worldviews
so even even many of the philosophers
who are most vociferous and insisting
but David Lewis for example who are most
vociferous in insisting that they take
contemporary physics seriously seem to
us not to take contemporary physics
seriously at all right that what we
actually find and and and we try to
diagnose a specific set of commitments
that we find in in most analytic
philosophy of analytic metaphysics
specifically which is a commitment to
the idea that the world is ultimately
made of little things and the dynamics
and processes in the world result from
those little things crashing into each
other
but those little things are having
distinctness independently of models of
the world as a whole so the book starts
with a sustained attack on analytic
philosophy analytic metaphysics we argue
that it as practiced in the world's the
best uh best philosophy departments
right now it's virtually all nonsense is
it virtually all presupposes
demonstrable false physics we then have
a couple of chapters on quantum field
theory arguing they're trying to tell
how the quantum field theory is in fact
inconsistent with the presuppositions of
most analytic metaphysics then a couple
of chapters in which we've tackled the
problem well so if we take real physics
seriously instead of the stylized fake
physics of analytic metaphysics what
about the special sciences what are the
status of one of the status of the date
look like they're about objects of
various kinds they seem to be
generalizing over classes of objects in
the earlier chapters we've projected
reductionist accounts of those objects
but at the same time naturalism we also
have we also argue against so-called
disunity theories so we argue the world
it is it is one of the set think and
reasonable things to ask of science that
it provide us with a general world - and
a general worldview implies a work of
view of one world so if one takes real
physics seriously what about special
Sciences so we deal with that in an
information theoretic using information
theoretic mathematics though not as
satisfied with those chapters chapters
really are waystations because they're
basically they're they're in English and
one of our arguments is we really can't
expect we shouldn't expect to be able to
say true and interesting things about
the general structure of the universe in
natural language but at least we do in
that we do to try to do it in that book
at that point of the infinite in that
point of our dialectic we are still
talking to philosophers in one sense
we're trying to show how we've got
alternative views consistent with our
new foundations of the favorite topics
of analytic metaphysician so but we're
now in the business of writing up more
popular and accessible version of that
book which we hope to have up in a few
years is pretty formidable well you're
you're you're already doing the work for
us Massimo so maybe we can yeah um so
I'll stop in a minute
the other the other main thing we do
have no distant this may or may not turn
out too well I'm sure I will at some
point say things that that come from
this base so I just mentioned we do it I
run a experiment like an onyx lab at the
University of Capetown
which also has its partnered with
Georgia State University we don't do
behavioral economics in the sense most
people are familiar with those we're not
trying to extract
psychological properties of individual
people we do experiments with large
groups of people because we're
interested in the in economic
information processing dynamics at the
population level we do sometimes put
people in fMRI scanners but even there
we're not interested in estimating their
individual properties we've got some
fancy some fancy econometrics for
scaling up to populations as for things
that I could change my mind about I hope
that I will change my mind I'm looking
forward to changing my mind about
philosophy of mathematics because I have
a different philosophy of mathematics
every month so I'm sure I'm not gonna
get through three days or talking with
all you people and come up with the one
I started I came in with
you